hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know I was pondering the other day what
oh yeah you might be wondering why I
don't have a beer to stroke while I
pondered well that's because I made a
very foolish bet the other day and asked
that guy with the glasses I bet him that
John McCain would win this recent
presidential election instead of that
other guy I forget his name I think it
was on the news once so since I lost
that that I had to go ahead and shave my
beard off what can you do well I hope
you're happy mr. glass is sitting there
all high and mighty in front of your
bookcase hello oh hello hey didn't hear
you come in by a minute what did you
shave your beard I thought the contest
was of McCain lost I had to shave it off
no I thought the contest was if I didn't
post the video with the contestants
answering the questions in a week I'd
had to shave my beard PS it's coming
soon well this is great we both shave
their beards off when neither of us
handsome what the hell else could happen
Who am I on the Internet why the hell
did you shave your beard off you weren't
a part of the contest
I just wanted to belong I saw me when I
was shaving the beard also I decide to -
will you guys be my friends though Oh
God how'd you shave that thing anyway I
didn't think you had a razor
I put cheese whiz all over my face and
then I let loose a bunch of hungry rats
they were so happy I named them all day
row oh dude don't tell me anymore it's
also how we went my bikini area to stop
and you were the part of the contest you
didn't have to change what change change
change
I'll give you a cheese wag piss off just
to let you know that video is coming I
assure you get out of here oh right this
is that guy with the glasses saying
there's no such thing as a stupid right
so I shaved off my beard for nothing
what a waste
well even though I will no doubt grow
another one I can't help but feel
saddened by the laws of my cherished
friend he's been on my lips for years
and now with a whisk of a razor he's
gone I'm not usually a sentimental
person but I feel only necessary to pay
homage to the first and original beer
that
it's been on my face for what seems like
eons so you wonderful scraps of face
buzz this is for you
you
I personally like to thank Sarah
McLachlan for writing the most overused
montage song of all time but I'd also
like to thank Green Day for being the
second runner up with I hope you had the
time of your life
sorry Green Day is just McLaughlin song
was a little bit sadder and this is a
time for Mourning
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it
so you don't have to that's right I have
a review to do you know I was pondering
the other day why so many people got
offended when I reviewed the movie
mortal comment I of course pointed it
out for the ridiculous piece of poor
that it was but I was surprised to find
a lot of people enjoying it why I mean
okay it's certainly not bad some other
films I've reviewed on beer but why do
so many people consider it as satisfying
movie well a lot of folks have emailed
me saying that it's not really so bad
once you compare it to the sequel that
came out two years later
Mortal Kombat annihilation I don't think
I've ever gotten so many requests to do
one movie practically every day someone
was asking me to review this well I gave
him the peer pressure I've decided to
look over this shit madness and all its
glory even the cover gives the strange
order to destroy all expectations well
judging by the first film I can safely
say that I have no expectations so this
shouldn't be that disappointing you want
to take a look so do i let's jump right
in
oh I'm sorry I seem to have popped in
the first movie these are obviously the
exact same credits no this is
anihilation on there maybe they just
printed it on the wrong cartridge yeah
look at that it's the first movie it
even says right there wait what oh my
god they use the exact same opening no
difference at all how'd she find these
a-holes why did you even need to see she
had new titles were there no red crayons
at the drugstore to cross it out and
just write anihilation over it wow these
guys are really going to extra mile so
it starts out with a mortal recap of the
first film Liu Kang won the championship
Raiden never shut up Johnny Cage and
Sonya got together I guess and I even
got out with some evil emperor's
daughter called katana or something I
don't know she was in the movie for like
and they all live happily ever after or
tubing it turns out that evil is
approaching as it starts writing Cirque
de Soleil on our heroes who find
themselves surrounded by some nasty
henchmen but our fearless fighters are
confident as Liu Kang gets on his guard
katana readies for battle
Sonia prepares for who the hell is that
that's not Sonia that's like a totally
different actress Raiden what the hell
is going on here ah you're not Raven try
the cage what are all these people
ah you're not Johnny Cage so wait a
minute if you're not Sonia you're not
Raven and you're not Johnny Cage then
what does that make me actually it turns
out that they got all new actors for
these characters which is kind of
strange because the first build
indicates that there will definitely be
a sequel so don't you think they would
have had the actors sign on for that
Frank you're right agent you've got to
get me out of this movie sequel I know I
did the first one but they don't even
have enough money for a new opening
sequence uh-huh uh-huh oh all right
I'll just have to fake my own death so
we certainly see a bunch of lightning
cool-looking creatures but just who are
these sideshow rejects who are
threatening our heroes yeah was created
in six days on the seventh
mankind will rest okay Jehovah's
Witnesses no it turns out that all these
baddies are working for the evil emperor
of darkness what's his name shoka
I shall con the only evil overlord who
dresses up like McGruff the Crime Dog as
long as the portal remains open your
world becomes my room and take a bite
outta crime
he's also accompanied by his Queen
Sindel who also happens to be katanas
mother did she give birth when she was 2
so the Emperor fights Raiden as he makes
fun of his George Washington haircut as
they show off their effects that are so
lame that even the angry video game nerd
could pull them off well but Kage wants
in on these crappy Photoshop effects and
enters himself into the battle but that
turns out to be a bad idea
Johnny Cage dies this films will get up
already he'll soon to the other
characters get it
so the rest of the heroes escape the
Emperor by entering some sort of
underground cave here Raiden tries to
explain exactly what's going on I
believe he has resurrected your mother
to keep these portals open indefinitely
by reuniting you with her he has a spell
will be broken your mother's soul will
be at peace and his portals closed
isn't that cute they think we give a
crap how could the Elder Gods allow this
I do not know but karma must be stopped
or your world will perish I beat Shang
Tsung I can beat Khan you are no match
for car if anyone's going to kill Khan
all right along with the gods so the
story is actually kind of hard to follow
I guess they have to split up and roam
between the realms of the human world
and out world as the Emperor slowly
merges the two worlds together their
goal I guess is to just find a way to
stop the Emperor as Evil Queen sounds
simple enough so how do we get a travel
by using the Caged balls from American
Gladiators of course just watch these
things move and that's not my crappy
editing or anything that's really how
they move look at these things
it's like taxis for gerbils on top of
that two people have to ride on it
facing each other thrusting forward and
heaving their bodies to make it go this
is like the most Awkward amusement park
ride in the world when visiting Six
Flags be sure to ride the fuck Bal hours
of uncomfortable on Bratz gold all
around out enjoyable fun it's like the
tunnel of love Holloway hits a hot ball
must be at least this perverted to ride
meanwhile we cut to the temple of the
effort where we see him discuss the
takeover of earth with his father the
merger has begun
is under attack and it is glorious I am
a ding did you make Raiden beg for his
life before he's tried him thank you
that was very necessary Raiden is it no
concern to us
Yuri I am there I have no use for
excuses I've broken a sacred space
plumbing so Lu Kang and katana are
attacked by the only robot aware his
dreads as they continue through another
action sequence where people are just
jumping around on strings
it's like Crouching Tiger Hidden
bullshit there's so many strings in this
movie I keep thinking there's a puppet
master at the top of the screen put the
string or the string but then I say buy
it from by your face
sub-zero wait a minute did he freeze to
death from the first movie
you killed my older brother oh that was
his brother 7 degrees Celsius ok I get
enough you killed my older brother so
why did you help us cuz I hated him he
was a douche we have a common enemy
sub-zero you must help us don't wait a
measure called him sub-zero ok ok maybe
it was scorpion the yellow guy who was
the brother in the first film that died
okay now that makes sense
so we're gonna encounter next
what's going on we saw both of these
guys die in the first movie why are they
suddenly back that they both have
brothers are they themselves brothers
are they clones are they the same people
but different actors all the other
actors are different so how am I
supposed to tell I follow lectures of
black hole theories less complicated I
mess I miss all the fighting scorpion
grabs katana and takes her back to the
Emperor's nananana meanwhile we cut to
Sonia who looks like she's pretty busy
breaking into Jurassic Park trying to
find more pointless fight scenes to bar
take it she comes across her counterpart
named Jackson who just had the best
steroid injection he ever had in his
life I know I stand back step back let's
see what I made whoa it turns out I'm
made of Awesome but a lost GI Joe action
figure comes in to make their escape a
little tougher I come free with any
happy meal so ninjas come in as we
partake in gasp another fight scene
behold my accessories they are all sold
separately
be careful what you hit all the buttons
mines empty me on the electric fence
my batteries are not included
motherfucker okay seriously how many
jump seeds can you have in a friggin
movie it's like they're fighting in a
trampoline Factory I look at these
ninjas the foot soldiers for more
frightening than them ass orange ah
so some you find some sort of flammable
malted milk or something and blows it as
a 25 roasting him alive this is not
covered by my guarantee then they have
to rush out of the building for the
biggest most incredible green-screen
explosion you've ever seen in your life
you know guys you don't have to blow up
everything especially if you don't have
oh I don't know the explosion
meanwhile Liu Kang roams the desert
searching for some form of life that can
help him get good time instead he comes
across an obvious wolf effect that they
cannot afford that two seconds of
mediocre special effects is known as
night wolf a Native American warrior who
looks suspiciously like spirit from GI
Joe and is just about as handy let's a
beat shao kahn you've got to pass three
tests first ones courage I don't have
time for these stupid games oh that's
not good the second challenge was stupid
games huh so night wolf tries to help
him discover his inner beast by showing
him task lifts from the other movies
that will bring out anybody's raging in
her beast look he's turning into the
Hulk you wouldn't like me what I look
angry
what Liu Kang didn't know apparently is
that when you find your inner beast hot
half naked women appear to offer
themselves freely to you
okay I'm not afraid I can clearly see
that no my heart belongs to another your
heart belongs to another
who well katana that shake you've known
for less than an hour
how does she own your heart and true you
just met this other woman but give her a
few minutes and you have known her just
as long unfortunately the young lady
doesn't take rejection well
and she transformed into a fearsome
ninja started whipping Liu Kang's ass uh
is it okay if we go back to having sex
so it turns out the young woman's name
is Jade and she was just testing Luke eh
yeah that's it to see if he would give
in to temptation he doesn't so I guess
she's joining him on his quest I don't
know makes about as much sense as
anything else meanwhile we see Sonya and
Jax as they to roam through the desert
there they come across here's a big
surprise someone else to fight guitar
you wish Oh glad to meet you you wish I
seriously cannot believe how many fight
scenes there are in this movie I mean
look at this it's just two women
fighting each other covered in mud
heaving their large breasted bodies onto
each other touching one another rolling
around grabbing each other's hair
hitting oh dirty messy mud all over
their bodies forcing their clothes to
cling to their skin ever so tightly
revealing this limb revealing their slim
feminine figures for all of us to see by
the employing at each other giving in to
their animal instincts claw one another
like acid hissing and screaming until
one of them comes out victorious the boy
Oh
shut up shut up yes you're a digital
Kitty aren't you just a dirty danger to
kitty
yes you are you get so after that scene
Sonja defeats you wish and is suddenly
attacked by um
Bowser's anorexic sister but it's saved
by chance who what's that
computer-generated sock puppet in his
place meanwhile we see reading and
talking to the gods as he tries to
figure out how the Emperor went against
the rules of Outworld and Mortal Kombat
ah a scene without fighting take it away
take it away right and then rejuvenates
himself trying to pull off the Billy
Idol look as he meets up with the rest
of our heroes we find out that our
heroes have to travel to Outworld to
rescue katana and I guess remove the
spell from her mother that makes her off
vampirish faster than you can say stop
fucking fighting another fight scene
pops up as we seen Raiders split from
the team to take on some more ninjas
so these guys gonna hit each other
could you maybe stop doing flips and
actually attack one another
lisanna just throw a punch flying out
look this is a Mortal Kombat its mortal
ballet
well I have enough of this fight let's
see how the other guys are doing
fighting the vampire chick but hey what
you bought are off-screen are you timing
I miss another possible girl-on-girl
action scene what a ripoff but they were
fighting a cello - so Liu Kang breaks
into the fortress to rescue katana I
guess it looks like smooth sailing from
here it's a trap Lu oh thanks
we got tell me that before or after he
cut my head off
so Liu Kang fights the worst fencers
cast Jimmy ever saw and gets katana out
of her cage here katana tries to use her
magic to break her mother from the
Emperor spell but her magic doesn't work
as the Queen escapes their grasp by
doing her Wonder Woman twirl so what now
if sindell is not the key to closing
Kahn's portals then Kahn has a higher
allegiance wait a second that tattoo
I've seen it before it is a permanent
mark that allows safe passage through
the portals for the bearer and his
passengers you know I think I just
figured out one of the major problems
with this movie there's no story
there's just explaining how do we stop
gone let me explain where do we go next
let me explain it's just explaining and
fighting and I get enough of that from
my own government so please explain to
us why you have that tattoo my father is
an elder God if your father's an elder
God what does that make on Shao Kahn is
my brother alright enough of these
cliches let's just jump to the final
fight scene where our heroes face off
against Khan and his warriors but wait a
minute why isn't reading coming well I
know perhaps he has some sort of
foolproof back-up plan to sneak in and
stop the Emperor taking him by surprise
so tell us Raiden god of whitening
what's your strategy to help our team I
will pray for you all
fuck you get your ass in there for I
mean what is he literally staying
somewhere in the back shouting don't
worry I'll bravely watch you die from
the sidelines after he doesn't serious
soul-searching Raiden does finally come
to his senses and fight his brother
finally a groundbreaking epic duel God
vs guy
brother versus brother an incredible
battle that will no doubt be the
highlight why are you even in this mummy
game over cick allottee alright so our
heroes have to deliver the big fight if
they use their martial arts skill to
their full potential best death ever
it's up to Liu Kang to stop the evil
emperor now but in what way should it be
decided will be decided as it should be
Oh Lord I'll come back but Luke Han
gives into his inner beast and becomes
whatever the hell doesn't but so does
Khan who magically transforms itself
into a giant okay how can we take this
seriously
Howard the Duck had better effects that
mess so Liu Kang of course defeats Khan
his father turns into a Rubik's Cube
they get katanas mother back restore
order to the world and they live happily
ever after
or do they yeah yeah they they do pretty
much but I don't I mean this movie makes
the first Mortal Kombat look like a
masterpiece I mean nothing in this movie
makes any sense or has anything
resembling positive entertainment so
does that make the first Mortal Kombat a
good movie no but it definitely makes it
a movie which is more than I can say for
this cake chef if you have a chance to
pass it up do so and never look back as
long as you live oh uh I limit sound
your credit guy remember it so you don't
have to